خرج هذه المظاهرات في عدد من المدن
والعواصم الاوروبيه نشاهد جانبا منها في
اوترخت بهولندا مانشستر لوكسمبورغ ميلان
وباريس وبرلين التي ينضم الينا منها
مراسلنا ايمن الزبير ايمن اذا نتحدث الان
عن توسع لنطاق هذه المظاهرات
ومطالب مستمره بوقف الحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه نعم اعداد كبيره من محتجين كما
تشاهدون هنا في العاصمه الالمانيه برلين
ولكن ايضا في مدن المانيه اخرى خرجت اليوم
لتطالب بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار هذا هو
المطلب الرئيسي الذي نسمعه في كل هذه
الاحتجاجات بالاضافه الى الحريه لفلسطين
علما ان الشرطه الالمانيه تضع قيودا حتى
على الشعارات التي يرفعها المتظاهر
المسيرات التي تجوب الشوارع
الالمانيه يتوقع ان تصل هذه المسيره بعد
قليل الى بوابه براندر بورج والهدف حسب
المنظمين هو الضغط على الحكومه الالمانيه
التي تعرضت لانتقاد شديد في هذه المسيره
المتظاهرون يرددون شعار يقول بان اسرائيل
تقصف تمنحها الدعم السياسي والدعم المالي
ايضا هكذا يقولون وبالتالي ياملون ان
تتغير مواقف الحكومه الالمانيه خاصه
للمطالبه بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار نعلم ان
الحكومه الالمانيه ترفض هذا الخيار الى
حدود الساعه بحجه انه قد يمنح هديه على حد
تعبيرها
لحماس لكن في الايام الاخيره كان هناك
تغير طفيف في موقف الخارجيه الالمانيه
التي طالبت عبر وزت ب طلبت اسرائيل باعاده
تكييف
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه ولكن ذلك يظل غير
كاف بالنسبه لهؤلاء الذين تساءلوا ايضا في
هذه المظاهره لماذا المعايير المزدوجه
لماذا لا يتم النظر الى الماساه التي
تعيشها غزه الى سقوط الضحايا من الاطفال
كما قالوا وبالتالي يتوقع ان تتكرر وان
تستمر هذه الاحتجاجات هنا في برلين وفي
مدن اخرى قيل لنا قبل قليل ان مدينه
هامبورج
ستشهد مسيره حاشده يوم
الاربعاء المقبل هذا يعني انه رغم اجواء
اعياد الميلاد ورغم اجواء البرد التي
تعيشها المانيا هناك اصرار على مواصله
الاحتجاج الى حين تحقيق الوقف الفوري
لاطلاق النار وادخال المساعدات كما يقول
هؤلاء لان الوضع كارثي في غزه بحسب
تعبيرهم
مريم المواقف السياسيه على ضوء هذه
المظاهرات المستمره
ايمن كيف تتوزع ايضا بخصوص ما يجري في
غزه نعم المواقف السياسيه في المانيا منذ
او بعد السابع من اكتوبر لم تتغير الى حد
كبير معظم الاحزاب التي لديها تمثيليه في
البرلمان تعتبر ان موضوع القضيه
الاسرائيليه على حد تعبيرهم هي قضيه
داخليه وهي تدخل في اطار ما يعرف
بالمصلحه العليا للبلاد شاهدنا كيف صرح
العديد من المسؤولين الالمان سواء من
المعارضه او من الحكومه بدعم غير مشروط
لاسرائيل وهذا الموقف الى حدود الساعه لم
يتغير الى حد كبير صحيح ان وزيره الخارجيه
انالينا بيربوك كتبت رساله الى جانب
نظيرها البريطاني تطالب بمحاوله البحث عن
هدنه مستدامه تدوم لسنوات ولكنها تعيد
وتكرر
ان المطالبه بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار قد
يمنح هديه لحماس وهذا ما يفسر الجمود
الالماني ان صح التعبير والاصرار على
الابقاء على هذا الموقف رغم الاحتجاجات
الكبيره التي تشهدها المدن الالمانيه
علينا ان نشير ان الموقف الرسمي لا يعبر
عن الموقف الشعبي الالماني
ال تظهر ان الشعب الالماني يطالب بوقف
فوري لاطلاق النار ويعارض هذه الحرب ويقف
الى جانب المدنيين الفلسطينيين هذه هي
الارقام المتوفره الى حدود الساعه لكن
هناك موقف حكومي مختلف تماما عن الموقف
الشعبي
مريم الموقف الرسمي لا يعبر عن الموقف
الشعبي وشارع الالماني راي مختلف عن
حكومته التي تدعم اسرائيل وتعتبر اي وقف
فوري لاطلاق النار قد يشكل هديه لحماس كما
تقول الحكومه الالمانيه وا لكن الشارع
يخرج في هذه المظاهرات المطالبه ب وقف هذه
الحرب وادخال المساعدات لسكان غزه وهم
يخرجون في هذه المظاهرات منذ ب هذه الحرب
وفي مدن المانيه مختلفه كما ذكر ايمن حيث
ستخرج مسيره ايضا حاشده يوم الاربعاء
المقبل في مدينه هامبورج الالمانيه الى
جانب المظاهره او المسيره التي نتابعها في
اعلى شاشتنا والتي تخرج في برلين كذلك
باريس العاصمه الفرنسيه تشهد هذه الوقفه
الاحتجاجيه
والمظاهره الرافضه لاستمر هذه الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه لاستمرار قتل
المدنيين في غزه وكانت هناك هتافات تدعو
لاستمرار ومواصله مقاطعه اسرائيل كما يقول
هؤلاء المتظاهرون الذين يخرجون ايضا في
هذا السبت لمره اخرى منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
ربما زوايا كثيره تلفت الانظار في مظاهره
كهذه نور الدين حدثنا عن
ابرزها الابرز ربما مريم هو عندما يصدح
هؤلاء بان فلسطين ستنتصر يقولونها باللغه
الفرنسيه ساحاول مع الزميل المصور عماد
التحرك الان لزاويه اخرى من هذا التجمع
اذكر بانه في فرنسا اليوم مريم اكثر من
مظاهره لعل اكبرها ربما هي في مدينه
ستراسبورغ شرق فرنسا وايضا مدينه ران ران
التي يمكن القول بانها حطمت الرقم القياسي
لا يكاد يمر اسبوع من دون ان تشهد هذه
المدينه مظاهره مؤيده لغزه وللشعب
الفلسطيني وللمطالبة
الساميه مشكلتنا هي مع الصهيونيه ومع
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي يقوم بقتل الابرياء
والمدنيين دعيني في 30 ثانيه اتحدث الى
احد الحضور هنا في هذه
المظاهره revendication
l'ul de la manifestation d'aujourd'hui
c'est gaza au secours puisque on en est
plus de 20000 dcsc probablement beaucoup
plus dans la rit
notre notre contre la complicit dont bf
le rime d' isra et puis aussi don des
outils des armes ceux qui veulent dans
la soci civile lutter pour la justice en
palestine et une de ces armes la
principale peut qui
nous offerte
ici
يصد شعارها غزه النجده غزه الانقاذ ويقول
بان هذه المظاهره هي في الحقيقه من نوع
المظاهرات التي تطالب بوقف الحرب على
الفلسطينيين ويقول بان نريد ان تكون لدينا
وسائل من اجل الدفاع عن سكان غزه ومن بين
هذه الوسائل هي مقاطعه اسرائيل على حد
تعبيره اذا مريم كما تلاحظين باختصار شديد
المظاهره مستمره الكلمات مستمره تلاحظين
الحضور اللافت للكوفيه الفلسطينيه وللعلم
الفلسطيني ايضا تلاحظين ولا شك هذه الصور
صور الضحايا الاطفال والمدنيين والسكان
الذين قضوا في هذه الحرب التي تشنها
اسرائيل منذ حوالي
76 يوما في غزه هذه اذا اجواء هذه
المظاهره في قلب باريس اذكر بان هناك
مظاهرات ايضا في مدن فرنسيه اخرى لا يزال
الشارع الفرنسي كل اسبوع كل نهايه اسبوع
يعبر عن دعمه لغزه وايضا لمعارض
تندي بهه الحرب واضا
تنديده السكوت الدولي على المجازر التي
ترتكب اخرج الى جانب باريس فيغان
وستراسبورج كما ذكرت نور الدين بوزيان من
باريس وايمن الزبير من برلين شكرا لكم